-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from her work on
"Westworld" and "Mildred Pierce"
and "The Wrestler."
She stars as Madonna
in the movie
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story,"
which premieres November 4th
on Roku Channel.
Let's take a look.
-Okay, here's my thought.
I think this is
a really great idea.
I hope you like it.
We team up, right?
I'll write all the, you know,
good songs, the real ones,
and then you parody them
every time.
Bam! Bam!
It's perfect.
[ Laughs ]
-Sounds great.
-It's fool-proof.
We'll be unstoppable.
We'll be the
hottest power couple
in the entire music industry.
What would our
power-couple name be?
I'm thinking Madyankovic
or Madonnavic.
Or maybe just Madonna.
-Please welcome back to the show
Evan Rachel Wood, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
I'm so happy to have you.
-I'm so happy to be back.
It's been a minute.
-It has been a while.
This is such a fun reason
to have you here.
This movie is a biopic
about Weird Al
that takes a lot of liberties
with the truth.
-Oh, it's 100% accurate.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
-Was it as much fun to make
as it was to watch?
-We had such a blast.
We had 18 days to shoot this.
-You shot it in 18 days?
That is no days.
-It's zero days, yes.
It's like student-film days.
-Yes.
-But we did.
We had an amazing cast and crew.
Daniel Radcliffe is, like,
an absolute dream to work with.
And I'm addicted to
comedies now.
I'm worried that I'm only
gonna want to do comedies now.
-Well, it was such a nice shift.
I mean, you're obviously
a wonderful dramatic actress,
but it was so much fun to see
you doing something
that seemed like --
-Is this what you guys do?
You show up
you and make each other laugh?
You don't have to get
dragged through the mud
or scream or anything?
-Yeah, it was very -- You do get
dragged through the mud
a great deal
in some of your work.
-Well, that is true. Yes, yes.
-But you mentioned working
with Daniel, which is so cool.
And I know you have
a 9-year-old.
Is your 9-year-old into
"Harry Potter"?
Was that a big deal that
you were working with Daniel?
-Of course, yes. Definitely.
We watched all of the
"Harry Potter" films together.
And I told him I would be
working with Daniel Radcliffe.
And he said,
"Oh, can I come to set?"
And I went, "Ah, no," because
I didn't know how to tell my son
that part of my job was
to just violently make out
with him
throughout the entire film.
I'm like,
"You can't come and watch mom
make out with Harry Potter, no."
-You're like,
"Even wizards grow up."
-Yeah. And -- Exactly.
And, you know,
but no playing with wands.
We're not going to do this, no.
-So, you play Madonna
in the film.
-Yes.
-And this is a -- You know,
there have been so many eras in
her iconic music career,
but this seemed like
a particularly fun era.
One of your favorite
Madonna eras?
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
I mean, I've been such a huge
fan of hers since I was a kid.
I would, you know,
fake sick so I could
stay home from school
to lip-sync
"The Immaculate Collection."
And I totally got busted by
my mom once, like,
in a mid-knee slide with
the candlestick microphone.
And, you know, I was like...
♪ Like a Pra-- ♪
And she was like,
"You're not sick, go to school."
So, yeah, I've been training
my whole life for this.
-How do you prep to
play Madonna?
Especially because there's got
to be a level of accuracy,
but, also, it's a comedy,
so you don't have to take it
as seriously as a biopic.
But you also
can't just mail it in.
-No. And I did take it
very seriously.
It felt like the pressure
was slightly off
because it wasn't
a Madonna biopic.
It was a parody.
But, yes,
I still wanted it to be good.
I kind of wanted,
you know, people to be like,
"Yeah, you know, the Madonna
biopic was really good,
but did you see
Evan Rachel Wood do
the Madonna in
the Weird Al movie?"
Like, that was kind of the goal.
-You have been lucky enough
to meet the real Madonna?
-Yes. Yes.
-And wow was your time with her?
-We had a lovely time together.
We had dinner once.
We've been very friendly.
I don't know if she'll be
calling me after this,
because I didn't know that they
didn't have her permission.
Once I signed on,
I found out we were like
halfway through shooting.
-Yeah. On day nine?
-Day nine, I was like,
"So, what did Madonna say
when you asked her about this?"
And they were like,
"We never talked to Madonna."
I was like, "Great."
-It will be very funny
if you get a text from her
that makes it very clear
that she's seen the film.
-Or I don't get
a Christmas card this year.
-Yes, exactly.
But it is such a --
And, again, that era, I think,
for everybody --
I mean, Daniel obviously has
a very fun wardrobe, as well,
getting to be Weird Al.
But dressing up like Madonna
from the '80s --
it's so much fun.
-I never wanted to take
the clothes off.
And every day,
I came to work thinking like,
"I wonder if this is
ever going to get old
or I'm gonna get jaded
about this."
Nope. It was always just as fun.
I couldn't stop doing
Dubsmashes.
Couldn't stop listening to
Madonna music.
We all had a great time,
especially, like,
hair and makeup, as well.
-You mentioned your kid
getting to meet Daniel.
Have you worked with
other co-stars over the years
that are impressive to
a 9-year-old?
-Yes, absolutely.
I mean, he could barely get out
a word when he met Daniel.
-And it should be noted,
Daniel, I would imagine,
has been through that before
and is probably the best at it,
maybe better than
anyone in the world.
He's the sweetest guy
in the world.
And he's very aware that
when he meets kids,
it's going to be harder for
the kid than it is for him.
-Exactly. I mean, I can't even
imagine how many times
he's been asked to do that.
Handled it so well.
I think my child
got out maybe three words.
And I was like,
"Daniel, thank you so much.
You know, sorry, you know,
they only said three things."
And he went,
"Oh, that's impressive.
Three words is very impressive.
Most kids just hide.
I don't even see them."
And so I was like,
"Okay, you did good."
But I think the only other time
he really geeked out
was when after
I had done "Frozen 2"
and he got to meet Josh Gad,
who does the voice of Olaf,
and didn't believe that he was
Olaf until he was like,
"Alright, close your eyes."
And then he whispered,
"I'm Olaf and I like warm hugs."
And my child just went...
And, like, you know,
major mom points.
-It can break different ways,
because every now and then,
I've been lucky enough to --
A friend of mine has done
a voiceover, and I do the same
thing with my kids.
And I think, sometimes,
they don't love it.
Like, they like to picture
the sort of clean lines
of animation,
and when they meet, like,
my scraggly dope friends,
they're like,
"Oh, I don't like this at all.
-"Ooh! That's not --" No.
-"I don't like that you
were in my iPad."
-I can imagine.
-You have a band.
-Yes.
-And your band
performed on Halloween.
-We did. We performed in
New York on Halloween.
-Have you often done
Halloween shows?
-We do a Halloween show
every year.
-Fantastic.
-Yes.
-I'm so jealous
at the fact you have
Halloween plans that you know
what they're gonna be.
-Every year.
-Yeah.
And you get to be onstage,
and I would imagine
people are having
the best possible time
at a show like that.
-They are.
And this was the first time we
had done a Halloween show
in New York.
And I always get, like,
slightly intimidated
because I love New York
and I always want to impress
the crowd, but I always forget
what a great audience they are.
They're so receptive.
They're, like, theater people.
They love a good show.
And so it was great.
We had an amazing time.
Everyone was singing along.
-Are you costumed on a
Halloween show?
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
This year, we dressed as
Miriam and John
from the movie "The Hunger."
It's a vampire movie,
yeah, from the '80s.
-[ Laughs ]
-What are you laughing?
-That is the deepest cut.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, Miriam and John
from "The Hunger."
I saw so many of those
this year.
-We're a niche band, you know?
-Yeah, you're a niche band.
Right, right.
And then, when you look out
in the audience, though,
do you feel like your audience
are niche with their costumes
or are you like,
"Oh, there's Mario.
There's Waldo."
-Well, I did see
a Judy Funnie from "Doug."
-Okay.
-That was a deep cut for me.
But I also see a lot of Dolori
is what I like to call them,
dressing up like
Dolores from "Westworld."
-Oh, that must be weird.
-A lot of blue dresses.
Yeah.
A lot of Dolori in the audience.
-Now, when you're performing for
people in costume,
do you, as a performer,
know there are people in costume
or do you allow yourself to
believe that those characters,
those fictional characters,
have come to see you in a show?
-Wow. You know,
I never thought about that,
but the next time I do a show,
I'm absolutely
going to think that.
-Well, look,
congratulations on the movie.
It is really so much fun and,
like I was saying backstage,
such a funny idea.
The execution
is so much more impressive.
I was delighted by how many
twists and turns there were.
And you're really great.
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-Always a pleasure to see you.
-Yeah.
-Evan Rachel Wood, everybody.
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story"
premieres tomorrow
on The Roku Channel.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."